we didn't talk about yet why you stopped
yes okay this is sad you had a heart
problem so
it was december 17th it was like week
before christmas
before christmas yeah and then the story
went viral about me jarring and selling
farts so not only was i selling now
farts to my you know my
my followers and my fans it was now like
people who read the story who came over
to my unfiltered and were like we heard
you sell farts so i had like double the
orders of the last batch it went crazy
it went freaking nuts so you don't have
any elves or
helpers no no it's just me by myself
well i have my two dogs but i won't
bottle and sell their farts you wouldn't
no those are just for me
you offer your dog's farts no but
they're cute
the farts are the dogs everything okay
everything my dogs do or is the cutest
thing in the world they can [ __ ] do
anything and i'll be like oh my god do
you have to fart yet
what do you have to fart yet no are you
trying my stomach hurts yeah
but um so
yeah it was december 17th like the week
before christmas and i was really being
irresponsible with my diet i was trying
to just force myself to fart as much as
possible so one morning i did three
extra large protein shakes and i ate
almost an entire pot of black bean soup
and you know i did what i had to do i
produced all the jars and i remember
it was almost i think 75 or so that i
did in that bag 75 farts yeah how long a
cup within a couple days which is like
the most i've ever do you live in a
house i do i have a nice house in
connecticut i love it can you get
roommates nope just live alone yeah
thank god because that would have
definitely been awesome you know they're
saying they're saying thank god all the
possibilities yeah well i don't like i
don't like living with roommates
stephanie can't come to the phone now
she's busy
oh she's
manufacturing oh my god okay yeah i mean
i live very in like a secluded house no
neighbors nearby no windows no windows
there's windows okay but you don't open
those because you don't want to lose
some of the product absolutely not go
ahead so you you're jamming you you
started yes and by the end of the night
i was feeling not so well i was having a
tightness pressure type feeling building
up around my chest in your chest yeah
and i have a pre-existing condition and
i just started birth control recently so
i was like thinking oh my god maybe i'm
having a blood clot or maybe i'm having
a heart attack or something's going on
so in the middle of the night i reached
out to my friend and i'm like can you
just take me to the er just so i can
have peace of mind so i can just like
get my you know vitals checked to make
sure i'm not dying because i couldn't
even breathe in i was laying down i was
like i kept adjusting moving trying
different positions to sleep and like
like i couldn't breathe in all the way
so i went to the er and i told them my
symptoms and they like seemed very very
concerned like okay yeah you're having
chest tightness and you can't breathe
we're gonna send you right in you don't
have to wait they did an ekg and they
did a blood panel to see if i was having
a blood clot and then they started
asking me questions about if i'd started
taking any new medication or if i had
any recent changes to my diet
and so then i kind of explained to them
that i had a lot of protein that day and
a lot of beans and that's when like i
think it clicked in their brains like
okay
maybe this has something to do with it
but the ekg came back fine the blood
panel came back did they ask why you
consumed that or did you tell them why i
told them that it was because i work out
a lot
i wasn't gonna tell them about my fart
jars i felt like that was too like it
was late at night i was like you know
what they don't need to know this
information this is private information
but you just say that you know this
morning i had three protein shakes and a
giant three pounds of beans
but you don't tell them why
because i work out
because i work out yeah
because i totally look like i do
no i'm joking but yeah so they
discharged me and they said that i need
to make adjustments to my diet and then
i should you know go home and take a gas
suppressant and i should also take a
tums to kind of like wait wait i get
because you had gas yeah they said it
was gas pain up in your chest yeah i
guess it was so much here that it was
pushing everything up it's kind of like
when you have acid reflux it can kind of
like imitate the feeling of like a heart
attack because you'll get that like
tight feeling here so
so
for you to take a gas suppressant like a
gas app game over
game over yeah
wait but what i don't get is after that
you're like i had my scare i'm not gonna
do it anymore why wouldn't you just i
mean you still obviously probably fart
because everyone farts why wouldn't you
just not do the extreme
slow down what tell the audience so they
don't feel bad everyone farts everybody
farts everyone farts so but why wouldn't
you just not do the extreme eating and
just whenever you have a fart bottle it
up and that one's worth more yeah so i
have been taking one or two orders here
and there
but the problem is is like when you have
20 people asking you for an order how do
you pick the ones that you're gonna send
an order right now that's tough you know
so
should we take the third caller on this
spot can we give it to one of our can we
like one of our listeners yeah
would you make a fart for one of our
listeners i'm you know what i i would
i would
oh my god
[Music]
you